las manifestaciones en perú continúan
los bloqueos que comenzaron en rechazo
al alza los precios de los combustibles
derivaron un reclamo en contra del
presidente pedro castillo parte de estas
movilizaciones y parte de lo que las
encuestas nos muestran que quiere la
ciudadanía no es sólo el cambio en torno
a las políticas que está ejerciendo el
presidente castillo e incluso la salida
de presidente castillo sino que se habla
de que se vayan todos es decir que
vayamos a unas nuevas elecciones tanto
presidenciales como regionales en la
región de ica en el sur del país los
transportistas se enfrentaron a la
policía
las manifestaciones han continuado pese
a que castillo anunció un acuerdo con
los transportistas el fin de semana en
el cual se comprometió a bajar los
precios de los combustibles además
aseguró que a partir del primero de mayo
el sueldo mínimo aumentará de 930 soles
a 1.025 cerca de 280 dólares en lima
donde se han registrado también masivas
protestas el malestar en contra del
gobierno es intensificado luego de que
castilla ordenar un toque de queda para
controlar las manifestaciones que luego
levantó vamos a permitir aquí nuevas
dictaduras ni que el perú lo sigan
hundiendo ya la furia del pueblo está
desatada por su parte el gobierno hizo
un llamado a la calma y argumenta que la
crisis económica se debe a la pandemia
de kobe 19 y a la guerra ucrania a las
personas que están infiltrándose en las
marchas de protesta ayer se ha visto a
un par de congresistas yo creo que esa
no es la tarea de los congresistas
asustar a la población a que tomen las
calles y hace ya causar daños además de
la gran movilización de este jueves los
manifestantes han asegurado que la
protesta se mantendrá hasta que no se
cumplan sus exigencias parte de esas son
que el gobierno controle el alza en los
precios de los combustibles y de los
fertilizantes